talking about having an impact on
culture we have someone else you need to
meet our series changing the game
profiles and extraordinary women who are
making a difference now and for future
generations this morning we're speaking
with one ceo who's helping break taboos
and redefining beauty standards from an
early age julissa prado struggled with
her curly hair she says she couldn't
find the right products to use so in
2017 she did something about it what did
she do she found a riesl's curls out of
her uncle's garage to make her own
products prada's family is from mexico
and rizos is a spanish word for curls a
lot of you already know that her company
is exploded in size and now her products
are sold at target and ulta beauty
stores all across america and she came
and she's got her curls rocking the
curls as always you lisa prado it's so
good to see you thank you for having me
here so you were that kid in the
neighborhood you you were drawn to hair
and people would always come to you and
say what do my hair do do my hair i
would do updos whatever they would ask
for i could do but you like but you
didn't like your own curly hair when you
were coming out well what would you do
to hide that
um
literally my first time i got my hair
straightened my cousins put my head over
an ironing board and ironed it straight
with a clothes iron
wow and you decided what what made you
decide you know i need to embrace the
curls number one your curls are
beautiful let me just say that i was one
of those people that said could i touch
your girls i know people don't like that
but you said i love it when people touch
my curls i love it because it make it
lets me know you appreciate my work of
me doing my own no i do i do so when did
the switch happen for you
um i think learning to love my hair
which was the quality that i hated most
about myself was the first step towards
learning to love myself and every part
of me so i think that was a very
important piece of that journey and i'm
just so happy that i was able to then
begin sharing it and helping other
people on their own journey as well but
it became a family business how to lisa
really let people understand what you
did to do this who did what in your
company yes so the drawing on my bottle
my cousin vanessa drew that the models
on my website were my cousins and i the
website i made my first headquarters was
my theo hans garage off of washington
and crenshaw and mid city where i grew
up okay okay every family member played
a role 100 self-funded completely
bootstrapped and um yeah everyone until
this day it's still family ran and
everyone still helps out and it's a
multi-million dollar company thank you
very much wow that's what happened that
is target that is awesome
there are stigmas around curly hair um
so what are some of those and how do
those stigmas affect people of color
specifically yeah i think
growing up there was always this like
internalized belief that your hair
wasn't done it was unprofessional unruly
unless it was straight and so i think
that led to a lot of you know kids of
color especially growing up thinking
that it wasn't acceptable and you needed
to change in order to me exactly oh you
had to get a perm and i remember exactly
my daughter now wears her hair natural
but i remember if i'd worn my hair the
way kirby wears hers today i was told go
comb your hair you look a mess it's not
done you need to you know go back in and
do something snappy yeah
number one you've taken the word nappy
out of the vocabulary i like that yeah
definitely and the products on the
shelves because of the stigmas around
curly hair were all as you put it had
straight hair tendencies do i have that
right what does that mean yes i think
it's so interesting that so much of what
we know about hair only applies to
straight hair because that's been the
norm for so long so how to style how to
cut it like um how to you know how often
to wash it etc a lot of these things
come from things that only apply to
straight hair and don't apply to other
hair so for example brushing your hair
dry if you have curly hair like that is
just so painful um also there's so many
things that people do that um kind of
take away from the volume and definition
so one of them is a lot of people
sometimes they'll get out of the shower
part their hair and then just start
brushing their hair down and this makes
your curls and your hair kind of stick
to your scalp and kind of create like a
flat here and just curly there but you
also say that all curls are not created
equal the beauty of your company is that
you have products that go for a full
range of curls including what you call
for the undercover curlies yes yes so
it's an undercover curly so undercover
curlies i have met them since i was a
little girl in bathrooms and elevators
they're kind of whispered in me like no
one knows this but i have curly hair
like can you help me like how do i get
my hair to curl like yours and i've met
them forever there's people that haven't
embraced their curly hair because they
always straighten it but um i'm here to
help you there's hope and there are some
people that don't even realize they have
curly hair right yeah yeah they take the
curly hair challenge people will not
know they haven't they've been putting
stuff in there oh yeah so many people
literally they'll just think like their
hair is frizzy and they've just been
straightening it their whole life yes
they just don't even realize that their
natural texture with the right products
that frizz is actually curl definition
so what i recommend is
yeah when you shower after you just let
your hair air dry naturally if your hair
air dries completely bone straight your
hair is straight but if there's like
texture if there's frizz if there's some
kind of something there got a little
something and it means like you either
have wavy or curly hair like there's
with the right products it will bring
out definition well the beauty of you
number one you are the best ambassador
for your company number one and your
energy is infectious yeah and i was
getting a little curl lesson because
curls go from one to four or something
all i can say is we are cheering you on
bravo you did this yourself you did this
yourself with the help of your family
and friends to put all your money into
it and here you are today so congrats
thank you thank you so much bravo her
name is julissa prado the name of her
company is resource curls recently
thank you so much